but what I'm gonna do first of all for
today's the but the bulk of today's
lecture will be on HIV and Ebola viruses
with more time spent on HIV because it's
potentially one of the mechanistically
best understood of the retroviruses and
it also has offered numerous
opportunities for therapeutic
intervention and there are a lot of
themes and terms that I can bring up as
I talk to you about the HIV virus
because you know it's just a great
exemplar of the of the viruses okay so
HIV is what is known as a retrovirus so
that sort of designates that there's
something working backwards in this
retrovirus based on its number in the
Baltimore classification it is what the
most recently identified mechanism of
viruses HIV stands for human
immunodeficiency virus and when you hear
the term HIV you'll often hear hiv/aids
where the AIDS part stands for acquired
immunodeficiency syndrome so what you
can start to tell about the name I might
down
is there something related to the immune
system with respect that this virus and
in particular it is that this virus
targets very specifically a population
of the cells that are critical in
immunity and when the virus attacks
those cells the person infected with the
virus becomes immunodeficient so that's
so I've told you about different viruses
some go for the liver some go for other
organs so like the liver that's the the
viruses that really cause deficiency and
liver function but this one is very
specifically deficiencies in the immune
function and it has been a tremendous
challenge developing vaccines against
hiv/aids because of the problem with the
immune system the other thing that I
mentioned who you lost in the last class
was that HIV is often found Co infecting
with TB patients people with those
microbial infections and that's because
that the immunodeficiency makes you more
susceptible to tuberculosis and
oftentimes there's a co-infection with
the two diseases and it makes the people
with TB really even less able to combat
the TB infection so that is really with
what gets a lot of the TB patients so
that's an important aspect to know and
it's also an important aspect to be
aware of when treating people for any
infection is if there's an HIV component
the the the body is much less able to
deal with mounting an immune response
because of the fact that the immune
cells are targeted
so HIV is an envelope virus that means
it has a membrane around it it is this
sort of peculiar shape where the outside
of the membrane is coated at the outside
of the buyer
is coated with membrane and then stuck
in that membrane a particular proteins
that are very critical for interaction
with the human host cells so these are
often termed GP proteins and the one
very important one is GP 140 and that GP
stands for glycoprotein now an important
aspect remember of virus lifestyle is
that they basically exploit all of the
human cellular machinery for their
benefit to make their proteins for all
of the basic needs of a cell so these
glycoproteins look like the
glycoproteins that are made by humans
because they're being made by the same
machinery that we would make the
glycoproteins in bacteria when we talked
about them it's a different machinery
that glycoproteins and glycolipids look
different but in HIV the glycoproteins
look like our glycoproteins and
therefore you could more or less
consider the HIV virus particle to be
coated with things that look sort of
human so that's a kind of decoy to the
human system anyway with respect to
recognizing a foreign entity so often
the glycans there serve as decoys to
make the human body think well there's
nothing wrong here now within the virus
there is RNA and a single-stranded
negative strand RNA so that's what puts
it into a positive positive so what cuts
it into a separate category is the fact
that the genetic material in the
retroviruses is single-stranded RNA and
it's the positive strand so far we've
talked about two other types of virus
mechanisms the double-stranded DNA
remember that was as an example that was
small
[ __ ] and we've also talked about the
single-stranded RNA negative strand and
our best example there was the influenza
virus which is a segmented genome what
you'll learn about HIV is that it has a
non segmented genome meaning that this
strand of RNA is one continuous strand
rather than separate pieces as we saw in
the influenza virus which was the last
example at the end of the last class now
let me just take a quick look so every
virion that would be a single viral
particle therefore will contain within
its structure the RNA and it will also
contain two copies of a particular
enzyme that are absolutely critical when
the virus infects a cell there's no time
for it to make anything it needs a
particular enzyme to get going with
replicating that message that initial
strand of RNA to start to come to make a
DNA double stranded DNA copy of it and
then make a messenger RNA so the enzyme
that's important there are two copies of
it of an enzyme known as reverse
transcriptase so basically the virus
structure is fairly simple there's a
capsid inside with the RNA plus the
reverse transcriptase that I'm just
showing as a filled circle here and then
surrounding the virion
is a membrane bilayer with GP proteins
stuck into that membrane bilayer that
are going to be important when Y starts
to think about the N tactility
by the virus right there's a second
a glycoprotein that's also important
which is known as gp41 and these are
very specifically part of this complex
but sort of associated with the GP 140
alright so now let's take a look at the
virus life site or details of this virus
but first of all I want you to take a
look at t-cells you've heard a lot about
t-cells they're a major component of the
immune system so I'm going to home you
right in on what the virus the virion
recognizes on t-cells and what makes it
such a disaster for the human immune
system okay so here are typical t-cell
receptors on the surface of t-cells just
as a recap I want you to remember T
cells produce unique antigen binding
proteins and that are put onto the T
cell surface and they provide cell
mediated immunity by destroying antigens
such as viruses but what the HIV virus
does is it really homes in on the cell
surface receptors of the T cells
specifically the HIV virus recommend
recognizing the cd4 recognizes the cd4
receptor which is a glycoprotein on the
surface of some t-cells that are
designated as cd4 positive T cells so if
you also you have circulating T cells
that would be the first place where the
HIV virus attaches to the C T cell to
cause infectivity thus debilitating the
the ability to mount the type of immune
responses that t-cells are involved in
so it's very important to now understand
why the sort of the physiology of this
virus is to knock out the thing that's
there to protect us from foreign
antigens which makes it so serious now
HIV will first started to emerge in the
early 80s it was more or less designated
as a death sentence
as you may be aware HIV circulated
around the gay community in the San
Francisco area very rapidly but it then
you know God became incredibly
widespread there's a possibility that
the jump of the virus from primates to
humans might of the virus might have
originated in Africa there's a lot of
work done on the origin of this virus
but it sort of came out of nowhere it
was something that was unexpected
unanticipated and hitting people just
like a cannonball and it was literally a
death sentence early on as the mechanism
of the virus became understood a number
of strategies could be put in place with
respect to antiviral therapeutics to
target this particular virus and what we
will see is the four types of targets
that have been sort of named as targets
for therapeutic agents why they work how
they work and we'll see the mechanisms
of those as to how they pertain to the I
and the HIV virus and we'll talk about
things like combination therapies so
early on there was really nothing
gradually early therapeutic approaches
started to emerge but they were
devastating treatments because the drugs
were so poor against the HIV virus
people were taking massive handfuls of
medications a day to try to stay ahead
of the virus as time has progressed
these therapeutic agents have been
improved and improved and now they're
relatively simple therapeutic agents
where you don't have to take massive
doses of fairly nonspecific therapeutic
agents but they're quite they're quite
sort of workable the problem is and
you'll see why people have to take these
therapeutic agents for lights once cells
are infected with HIV there will always
be a population of the of the virus
genetic material in the human genome so
you can't just say I feel way better not
taking these drugs anymore because there
is the chance that in some
in some of your cells the virus genetic
material is still there and you'll see
which enzymes in HIV are responsible to
that okay so let's take a look here at
the group six H I retrovirus named
hiv/aids in 2015 there were 37 million
people infected nowhere near enough in
treatment about half of those in
treatment and about 1.2 million deaths
this may account also for people co
infected with TB I mentioned to you when
we started talking about infectious
disease I really encourage you to go to
the NIAID website there is tons of
really interesting information not just
sort of from a clinical perspective but
from a mechanistic perspective from a
treatment perspective there's really
important things so I really encourage
you if you are interested in infectious
disease the national institute of allah
allergies and infectious diseases
component of the nih is the one
responsible for all the research on
infectious disease and in fact for many
many years during the crisis with HIV
there were special earmarked funds for
Risa any research towards the
development of therapeutic agents so
what happens how does this virus this
little particle that I've shown you here
I should really show you this is the
capsid and I should really show you the
membrane a little bit more encircling
that with the capsid inside so the
cartoon that you see on the screen is
more is more correct
so here's the virion particle it has
inside it the capsid that includes the
single-stranded RNA it only needs to
code for very few proteins remember
because the virus just exploits
everything else from the human host and
GP
1:20 sorry for that typo please correct
that and gp120 is displayed on the
surface of the Burien and in fact its
gp120 that interacts with the cd4
receptor on the surface of a target host
cell a t-cell now there is a second
receptor that's quite important it was
not discovered until quite a bit later
on it's designated as the co receptor
and the interaction of the virion with
the host cell is only good when there's
both the cd4 receptor plus the co
receptor and this was found through
careful biology that realized there was
another critical component for the
infectious disease and that is
designated as the ccr5 receptor or cxcr4
receptor so both receptors on the
surface you the virus has evolved or
selected out to recognize cells that
have both of those types of receptors on
the surface which ends up making them
very targeted towards the t-cells once
that association occurs then becomes the
process of fusion so remember I told you
that things large things can get into
cells by sort of merging a membrane with
the membrane a surface of the cell so
what is happening as those two receptors
are engaged is the virus membrane is
coming close to the host cell membrane
and starting to fuse through the action
of gp120 along with the receptor and the
cd4 receptor and co-receptor and I'm
going to show you a movie that shows
that part of the fusion because it's
really cool to see it in action once
that fusion occurs the virus membrane
actually just merges with the remote
with the remainder of the host cell
membrane and you drop the capsid into
the cell which then becomes unpackaged
to release the single-stranded RNA
that's the contents of that and what's
important to know
whoops goin backwards is that the minute
the single-stranded RNA gets into the
cell that needs to be processed but it
needs to be processed with an enzyme
that is unique completely unique to the
virus and that's the reverse
transcriptase without the reverse
transcriptase being there it's just RNA
that's just going to get chewed up in
the cell so what reverse transcriptase
does it reverse transcribes RNA into DNA
so that gets you on the track to the
infectious process in the absence of RT
you don't get there you don't you're not
able to make a DNA copy to then make you
know a copy of the RNA and so on so
reverse transcriptase that is why the
reverse transcriptase has to be
delivered along with the virus it can't
be just the virus with the genetic
material it's got to have this
particular enzyme with it so reverse
transcriptase is responsible for
converting RNA into DNA and as you all
know that is not the usual direction
with respect to the central dogma we're
always talking about DNA to RNA but
you've also heard throughout the course
how handy this reverse transcriptase
material is when we talk about arrays
and loads of biotechnology using reverse
transcriptase is super valuable let's
say for example we don't want to
sequence a genome we want to look at the
transcriptome the part of the genome
that's really important for being
translated into proteins what we do is
we collect the transcriptome but reverse
transcribed it into DNA which is a much
more stable tractable material for
sequencing and so on and so forth
so RT has become kind of a gift to
biotechnology and biological research
and it came it was inspired from the R T
in the HIV virus so that's very
important so the reverse transcriptase
then makes a
DNA copy of the RNA and then a second
complimentary copy of that DNA is made
to make double-stranded DNA which
represents the viral genome but in the
format of a double-stranded DNA that DNA
can be then taken here's the fun part
that DNA is actually then taken into the
nucleus and it's zippered in to the host
genome by an enzyme known as integrase
so it's not that you have this virus
junk and then you send it back out again
with the mature particles you actually
put this in the permanent copy of your
DNA in the nucleus and that is why
people don't get cured from hiv/aids
they have to take treatment for the rest
of their life because that DNA is
permanently in the copy of your genome
that gets replicated every time your
cells divide and so on so you can
understand the seriousness of that event
so that gets taken in into the genome
but also when it's time to make new very
ons the DNA is transcribed into
messenger RNA the messenger RNA leaves
the nucleus gets translated into
proteins and those proteins form the
basis of the new very on particles
now I mentioned somewhere here that it
is a non segmented genome so initially
the messenger RNA is a single segment
that then gets translated into a single
segment of protein which is known as a
poly protein so there are no stocks
between the various genes encoding
frames within the messenger RNA so that
gets transcribed by the host machinery
straight into a poly protein that's all
glued together in a single long piece
but then there is another in
Horton's HIV enzyme the protein the
protease that chops those portions of
the poly protein up into you sub useful
and usable portions so you also need the
protease readily available rapidly to
start dicing up the poly protein into
usable protein segments for the new
virus assembly so let's take a look here
what happens you the messenger leaves
the nucleus you make a bunch of proteins
that then get you make a poly protein
that gets digested into protein segments
and then everything accumulates at the
inside surface of the membrane and
starts budding off the virion
when it's first barded off it's not
really ready to go it's not intact it
has to develop a little bit further to
become a mature very on moving forward
to go infect another cell so the the
initial stage that budded stage of the
virion
is not completely competent to go infect
and in fact some there's been some
thoughts about can you ensure that the
immature virion doesn't develop into the
mature very on because that would be one
way of targeting the system okay so
there are a few different pieces the
reverse transcriptase the integrase the
protease and then finally these are all
critical processes that have been the
targets of therapeutic agents they are
molecular targets such as enzymes and we
know how to address enzymes with
inhibitors and one last feature of the
virus lifestyle cycle that has been
focused on with respect to therapeutics
is the viral fusion
so there have also been efforts at a
molecular level to try to inhibit this
process where you go your virus particle
docks down on the cell and somehow the
but the membranes fuse and then the
virus dumps its contents into the cells
okay this is just well it's just sort of
a quick sort of more beautiful view but
in a minute I'm going to show you a
video but I thought it was kind of nice
because it really allows you to look at
the different steps in the virus
lifestyle recognition fusion delivery
making the double-stranded DNA
integrated the DNA into the genome and
making new viral proteins so those steps
they're pretty logical it's just like
step one I've gotta find my target step
two I've got to stick to my target step
three I've got to deliver my genomic
content into my target and so on so I
don't want you to think like this is a
bunch of steps to memorize they all sort
of make sense in a logical progression
of events to make the virus be able to
go all the way through to budding off
new immature and then mature very ons
and so as I mentioned over there these
are the four targets that I'm going to
describe to you with respect to
therapeutic development and this is
where they all work the fusion early on
the reverse transcriptase taking that
single stranded RNA to a DA DNA copy the
integrase which zips the genomic
material into the genome and the
protease that cleaves up the long poly
protein to make mature pieces of protein
that are part of the virus okay so let's
talk first of all about viral fusion and
as I mentioned when I get to showing you
the it's a really beautiful video from
the AJ Howard Hughes Institute that
really shows the fusion very well but I
want to describe the fusion to you sort
of at a molecular level and then you'll
see later
you'll see it a little bit more real
life so what I said to you is that gp120
and gp41 which are these proteins that
are in the surface of the envelope been
recognized the co-receptor and cd4 t1
and form a complex so it's a complex
that involves what's on the virus it's
actually in a trimeric structure with
the two receptors that are on the host
cell and they form a pretty close union
and then what happens is there are a
series of events that tug the two
membranes together mechanically linked
to conformational changes of the protein
and basically splash the two membranes
together for a fusion event so it's
through the mechanic conformational
dynamics of that large complex happening
in sequence after the first interactions
that get you to a fusion event so these
get initially look like this but then
they start changing their shape and
making a fusion event so you could look
at it as initially you have the complex
formed but then later on there's been a
twisting of the structures the large
macromolecular structures to fuse the
membranes so for quite a few years and I
don't think it was the most successful
of the approaches with respect to
therapeutics people thought that maybe
you could inhibit the interaction
between gp120 and those receptors with
small molecules that might inhibit the
progress through the fusion process so
that was deemed a viable target it's not
the same as an enzyme target but it's
definitely a critical point in viral
infection and what was made were short
peptides that might stabilize this
complex and avoid the structure moving
forward to the few to the fusion related
complex so that was one sort of series
of events so those peptides were
designated as C peptides they would bind
to this portion up here that's pointed
to at the end they'd stick and they
basically Jam the cogs they'd stopped
that
event occurring by by binding quite
tightly to part of the fusion complex
okay the drugs the therapeutic agents in
that case were peptide ik kinda large
they don't diffuse into cells but that's
not a problem because this target is
outside the cell so there's no need for
that to get into cell for its effect all
of the other therapeutic agents I'll
describe to you are molecules that need
to get into cells in order to do their
job but the this particular strategy
didn't involve that that which was why
it was fairly attractive early on
because it was a very different target
from the others so the next step I want
to describe to you is inhibition of
reverse transcriptase so this is a RNA
dependent DNA polymerase kinase so
different from the other DNA polymerase
is we have DNA dependent DNA polymerases
but we don't have the RNA dependent ones
and so the types of strategies that were
used initially was to use types of
analogs of the nuclear sites that will
be used in polymerization so the reverse
transcriptase the first types of targets
what's going on down there first types
of targets were nucleoside analogs
because they can inhibit the
polymerization and you're gonna realize
you know quite a bit about these when we
first look at the structure so I'm going
to describe to you what are known as
nucleoside analogues
what does this term mean nucleoside
means it's a nuclear base plus a sugar
there's no phosphates because remember
there's an S there and it's an analogue
meaning it's not one of the native ones
but it that looks good okay I'll grab
her and you get the bag okay so it's a
nucleoside analog meaning it isn't the
standard water nuclear sites that you
put into your DNA and the most critical
first line actually became a zero
thymidine so look that's the thymine
nuclear base it's a sugar but it's
different from the regular ribose that's
either in RNA or DNA and it's two deoxy
so it looks more like a DNA building
block but check it out at the 3-prime
site there is an azide what do you think
this thing does or have I already told
you yeah what do you think this thing
does to stop the virus marching forward
and turning its RNA into a DNA copy can
it can it polymerize no so what do you
think so what how does it work it was
yeah just yeah it just grinds to a halt
what technology does this remind you of
yeah so it's really cool I mean we're
using something like this for sequencing
blocking the chain grows to get pieces
so we can tell the sequence but this is
a very viable drug could the reverse
transcriptase for kind of similar
reasons because it stops translation
s.korea stops it stops stops
polymerization now there's one important
thing that I need to tell you about this
a Z T as its termed a zero thymidine AZT
is what is known in the industry as a
prodrug
it's not the actual drug why is it a pro
drug what has to happen to it to be
useful why is it handy to have a pro
drug I know there's a lot of questions
there but they all kind of tied together
so it's a pro drug it can get into sales
right what has to happen to it for it to
be useful in inhibiting reverse
transcriptase because it won't do it all
on its own look at that structure that's
there's something missing in that
structure what are the building blocks
in the polymer aces are they nuclear
sites no up there yes exactly so you
have to convert this neutral molecule
that can sneak into a cell by kinases
that put phosphate groups onto that
molecule so that that molecule can get
engaged in polymerization you can put
one nucleotide onto a growing strand but
then it can't go any further because of
that azide oh group at three which would
be the normal place you grow so pro drug
strategies are very useful it's a way of
having drugs that aren't quite drugs yet
but they become drugs once they are at
their location it's not handy to use the
triphosphate of AZT as a drug because it
can't get in the cell so we deliver a
cellular Lee available molecule we let
the promiscuous enzymes in the cell
convert it to a triphosphate and then it
becomes a real drug the mature drugs so
I think that's a very important thing
about these types of therapeutic agents
and what I want you to know is that many
many viruses are treated with nucleoside
analogs performing similar sorts of
things but in some cases there's a lot
of different tailoring goes on with the
nucleoside analog it doesn't always work
to have the
the azide C 3 prime some of these
features don't always work so these have
to be tailored in different ways to
target different viruses because in this
case a ziti hits reverse transcriptase
but there may be a different flavor of
enzyme that you polymerase enzyme that
you need to inhibit in other organisms
so there's a lot lot lot of options yeah
there can be but I think the most
important thing is that it's the it's
very the RT is very promiscuous so it's
much more likely to pop this building
block in and that doesn't have the
mechanisms to reverse that reaction all
of the cleanup that gets done with
normal DNA polymerase so our DNA
polymerase is going to be a lot more
tuned up to avoid these mistakes but the
viral reverse transcriptase just churn
through and making making it so we're
protected by our own proofreading and
other types of mechanisms to avoid it
really messing up Tran replication but
that's a very good point ok so remember
the central dogma and this is why this
process confounds that and that's as it
Oh thymidine and we've already discussed
that so the next the next enzyme that
became quite an important target because
it was a new target was integrase so I
will tell you though that reverse
transcriptase inhibitors like AZT were
used early on but people with the the
the virus rapidly developed resistance
to to that therapeutic agent it was one
enzyme that was just mutating like crazy
and the organism could slip through that
net so the the development of
therapeutic agents didn't stop with AZT
was like we need to hit other targets
to have a therapeutically viable
combination of therapies that can really
stop this virus effectively so a next
enzyme that was targeted is integrase so
this is the one that's been targeted
most recently and there are currently
several integrase inhibitors integrators
of fascinating enzyme because it really
is the the enzyme that actually stitches
that piece of viral DNA right into the
right into the human genome just so it's
able to be replicated transcribed and
translated at any time so integrase has
been targeted it said was a tricky
target hit but as you can see with
several of these drugs there are
successful drugs one thing I want to
remind you about a lot of the names of
the agents if you see avir within the
name of a therapeutic agent it means
it's an antiviral so that's a clue that
all of these compounds are given names
while tegra vir I don't know who comes
up with these names but nevertheless
there are all names that end in a vir so
if you see you know a medicine and ends
in a vir it's an antiviral agent now the
last of the really fascinating enzymes
are was targeted it's the HIV protease
because the HIV protease is very very
different from many proteases in
mammalian biology it's a simple dimeric
structure it contain includes so it has
quaternary structure it has two monomer
units that are 95 amino acids 99 amino
acids each and each monomer contributes
to an active site contributes an
aspartic acid to an active site and
those are involved in the mechanism and
what generally happens when substrates
are inhibitors bind is these two flaps
one of them I've shown you in magenta
close down and close up the
active site and Ratana bia was one of
the first generation protease inhibitors
that sat in the place where in where the
substrate would normally sit in the HIV
protease and remember that the HIV
protease is critical for maturity of the
virus because it chops up the poly
protein into the necessary enzymes they
can't be functional enzymes in the poly
protein they have to cut up into the
appropriate pieces so the HIV protease
had unusual specificity and as soon as
it was discovered and structurally
characterized every major pharmaceutical
company jumped on this was in the late
80s to make successful protease
inhibitors that just got better and
better
ritonavir is an example of first
generation but i think now we're on
third generation type inhibitors which
just are better and better and much more
selective and specific for the HIV
protease and because they're much more
potent instead of needing grams and
grams of an inhibitor you can get away
with milligrams of inhibitor which made
the therapeutic dosing for HIV much more
palatable as sort of a good word because
when you have a very promiscuous
protease inhibitor like the early ones
that were discovered they mess up your
entire GI because your GI runs on
proteases that digest your food so the
original the early protease inhibitors
had a lot of side effects the most
modern third generation are very viable
and this just shows you what the topic I
want to hit on next is here's the green
and cyan two monomer units of HIV
protease in yellow is an inhibitor that
is bound and just on one monomer of the
two monomers I've highlighted in red
different resistance sites so when any
of those sites mutates the protease
stops work stops being inhibited by HIV
by the HIV protease inhibitors because
you want to think about it one mutation
in one subunit actually will have a
corresponding mutation in
partner subunit that is in the dimer
so each mutation ends up being two
mutations in the tetra in the full
enzyme that has quaternary structure so
these are major all that go they go all
the way out to the X the outer parts of
the enzyme it's not just around the
active site it's just all over the
enzyme you can get mutations that stop
the typical drugs that are targeted at
the protease is binding so here I just
show you these are data that show for
the protease and for the reverse
transcriptase within the length of the
protease for example there's mutations
all the way along I don't know why this
is 101 the numbering system is a little
different in some variants but you can
see which mutations will add to drug
resistance and there's a similar picture
here for reverse transcriptase okay so
this is a very serious issue so now I'm
gonna give you a little break here so
this is HIV it's a typical retrovirus
meaning that it has an outer envelope
and in the center it has two copies of
RNA as well as an enzyme here in blue
that's reverse transcriptase which will
ultimately turn that RNA into DNA
the the virus itself with this outer
envelope protein actually directly
infects T helper cells the way that it
does this is that as it comes up to the
cell surface it uses receptors that are
on T helper cells and exclusive to T
helper cells which are cd4 molecule
which really defines T helper cells it's
a surface receptor that binds to the
envelope protein it that causes a
conformational change and allows a
second receptor to grab hold of the
angelus this is the key kind co-receptor
it's also called ccr5 and we'll talk
about that more what happens now is that
the the the stalk of the envelope
protein pierces through the from the
virus into the into the host cell and
starts to draw the two cell membrane
membrane in the viral membrane together
and what ultimately happens is fusion of
those two membranes and the viral
genetic material is injected essentially
into the cell and the envelope protein
is left at the cell surface so that's
the fusion process that's so the virus
has a matrix and a capsid protein shown
here in green and red that that
essentially are digested when it enters
into the cell that releases viral
enzymes in the viral RNA and here we
have reverse transcriptase which takes
the viral RNA and using host nucleotides
converts that viral RNA into a single
strand of DNA while it does that it
makes some random errors which is
characteristic of reverse transcriptase
it has very poor proofreading activity
that single-stranded DNA now is again
reverse transcribed into a double
stranded DNA at that point another
enzyme that has come in with the virus
in the beginning called integrase
essentially grabs hold of that double
stranded DNA and carries it through a
nuclear pore into the nucleus of the
cell within the nucleus of the cell it
finds the host chromosome and it
basically the integrase enzyme makes a
nick in the host DNA and allows for HIV
to insert itself into the host
chromosome and that right there is what
establishes lifelong infection now RNA
polymerase comes along and makes
messenger RNA it's just back to normal
now those messenger RNAs encode for
different viral proteins they end up
associating with ribosomes on at the
surface of the rough endoplasmic
reticulum and here's a piece of mRNA
that's making envelope protein which is
directly produced into the endoplasmic
reticulum and it's shuttled then through
the endoplasmic reticulum and taken to
the cell surface where at the cell
surface it becomes embedded in the
cellular membrane and at this point
coalescing with other anvil
proteins that have been produced he was
gathering all of this infected 120
employees at the same time there are
other messenger RNAs that are being
produced that allow for translation of
other viral proteins so here are
additional viral proteins being made
which are going to be used to make up
the key components that that the virus
ultimately is going to need these are
transported again to the cell surface to
the area where these envelope proteins
are and a strand of RNA as well as a sum
of the enzymes are part of that complex
this then buds off at the cell surface
at this point but it's still not a
mature virion because the poly protein
chain needs to still be digested into
its component parts the protein that's
done by an enzyme called protease
protease breaks up those poly protein
chains and ultimately allows for them to
coalesce and form the mature structures
that make up the final virion and now
you have a mature infectious virion that
can go on now to infect other cells once
that happens now the cell can produce
tons of viruses and this is really what
then keeps the whole process going okay
all right so I have gone monstrously
long on HIV so sadly I cannot get you to
Ebola but I'll post those slides anyway
this just speaks this question just
speaks to combination therapies so
combination therapies are very very
important particularly in cases where
resistance to individual therapeutic
agents against an individual target can
happen so HIV mutates its proteins very
very rapidly but the likelihood that it
will simultaneously mutate to targets in
one cell is much lower so combination
therapies basically are there to avoid
drug
resistance that occurs usually because
of the high mutation rate not because
one drug has a short health half-life
not so that multiple strains can be
targeted or to decrease the number
side-effects obviously combination
therapies give you more side effects but
there's really important in mitigating
the disease so I was gonna talk to you
about vaccine development but I will
discuss what this was Professor Martin
to see if he who wants to take that over
but I want to leave you with one last
thing okay
three small points on next Wednesday
this is a Fred Flintstone
I'm Channel I tend to channel Fred
Flintstone cuz he wears this nice blue
scarf next Wednesday is the last of the
classes we've got some good stuff lined
up for you we're gonna have the
topoisomerase a demo from some people
who submitted a topo demo for us and
then we're gonna do 701 six jeopardy now
don't think this is gonna be cheesy it's
gonna be tough and it's gonna be fun and
we're all going to be involved professor
Martin and I will be the hosts you
promised to dress up Jack Jackie will
help me run the program because within a
real jeopardy program and Hannah and
David will keep scores and we'd like to
encourage you who come to be in pairs of
teams of two otherwise they'll be kind
of a lot of you so if when you come in
if you sit on that side of the room put
your two names on these boards and if
you're on the other side put them on
these boards because Hannah and David
will be posted there to keep score and I
will we will muster up some small prize
for the winner here so yes question that
would be a heck of an incentive wouldn't
it what this will do for you is actually
kind of help you refresh a lot of things
maybe identify blind spots it was worth
asking it was a good question yeah
so and that's all I'll post the
questions afterwards as well so you know
you'll be able to kind of sake I don't
know what this question was about at all
and you can go and review a little of
the material nice try though oh and um
there was one other thing I just want to
remind you that a boat is a boat
it's a Democratic Society so you should
please take time to fill in the
evaluations on the course okay
you